I want to ask you about your fan base
you used to have a very probably clear
idea especially early in your career who
your fans would be now you walk around
you appeal to a much wider audience yeah
you got to be shocked sometimes by the
kind of people that come up to you and
say they know your work they love it or
what they even know you from
man I had this lady she had to be 71
maybe she came up to me she had
headphones on and she was like I'm
listening to your song right now like
what you listening to you can do it put
your back into it
okay okay okay okay I'm like all right
so I don't know my fan base you know
they they just they morph into you know
you know 71 17 it's just all over the
place and you don't know they know you
from the music do they know you from
movies you know got
people you think that would know you
from your movies know you for music like
71 year old you could do it put you back
into it lady right and then you got
people who you think should know your
records you know what I'm saying and
they just know you from a movie so you
know it's crazy out here man the
problems I got to deal with out here
well it's about 22 Jump Street made how
much over the weekend 60 60 something
million dollars man a lot of money yeah
I think it came close to break it's like
number two all-time you know for a movie
that weekend I believe an R-rated movie
that weekend which is just insane it's
crazy so now you got to be thinking uh
uh is there gonna be a there's gonna be
a 23 Jump Street yeah you know it's like
only thing that will hold that up is
probably my salary you know
I wish they would have to pay me to be
in it but you know uh I hope so 23 Jump
Street let's do it yeah you're okay with
like 23 through 27. as long as they come
through as long as they come through I'm
with it fixing to be there you know if
you want to be in one uh Captain Dixon
to cuss you out too
I get to be in a movie yes come on you
just said I annoy you you do that's why
you perfect for a movie Kevin Hart did
it we made a whole lot of money I mean
you could do it that's right a lot of
money I could come in and be like hey
chief there's a big problem over there
work on the script we'll work on the
script that's my line Chief there's a
big problem out there
[Laughter]
listen I can't help you
after 21 years Andy gave up
in time ago he's not going to help you
out you better keep them checks coming
I do uh all right we have a clip here
from 22 Jump Streets you know exactly
which scene this is I think this is uh
the only scene we probably can show on
TV uh and it's where I send them to
college right so you you explain to them
how this one and in fact you explain to
them how this movie is different from
the last one definitely yeah let's take
a look at this clip from 22 Jump Street
same identities
same assignment we're going back to high
school you look like you're about 50.
you're going to MC State somebody's out
there and cooking up a new drug it's
Adderall mixed with ecstasy mixed with
God knows what else just bite wipey
wiping Wi-Fi stands for work hard yes
play hard yes now these kids get laser
focused for about four hours of studying
and then they party like it's 1999.
we're going to college for real why
every time you speak I want to throw it
up infiltrate the dealer find the
supplier
but you know what I got to be honest
with you I did see me coming in on that
scene at the end and the next movie I
saw that's the perfect place for me to
enter and annoy you okay coffee chief
cheese
look at this annoyance is real oh boy
it's palpable hate and annoyance that's
gonna light up the street okay
shut up and plug the movie right please
yeah okay